el periodista antonio de la cruz murió a
balazos en la puerta de su casa salía
con su hija quien también resultó herida
y su esposa
y los puedo
participar es que no vamos a encontrar a
los responsables
y vamos a aplicarle todo el peso de la
ley usted es mejor que nadie sabe
en mi gobierno jamás a ti tu vida
de los criminales según su familia de la
cruz abierto crítico del gobierno local
no había recibido amenazas por su parte
el diputado local gustavo cárdenas culpó
del crimen a las autoridades no está
confirmado la muerte de toño de la cruz
esta es una acción donde los principales
sospechosos son los funcionarios del
gobierno del estado la organización
artículo 19 advierte que muchas amenazas
a reporteros provienen de funcionarios
públicos en un estado en el que los
vínculos entre la política y el crimen
organizado han sido ampliamente
denunciados desde el periódico expreso
donde trabajo 23 años piden que el caso
sea esclarecido con méxico atraviesa por
una crisis grave en términos de
violencia contra el periodismo en la que
la impunidad desafortunadamente sí es
una constante que aquí mismo en
tamaulipas ha habido muchos asesinatos
de compañeros que han quedado impunes
nuestra exigencia es muy clara que sea
la fiscalía estatal o la fiscalía
federal pero que este crimen se
esclarezca que se dé con responsables y
que se les castigue la fiscalía abrió
una investigación para las causas sin
embargo se teme que la muerte de antonio
de la cruz no se esclarezca cuando los
datos oficiales dan cuenta de una
impunidad del 90 por ciento en
agresiones contra activistas y
periodistas